the search for the most immersive
interactive gameplay experience is over
but the fight for survival has only just
begun in case you missed a few key
details here are all the clues you need
to puzzle out the ending to escape room
the premise of escape room revolves
around a group of strangers who receive
invites to a competitive escape game
purportedly the most immersive
experience of its kind the game is being
put on by a company called Minos escape
rooms and name that suggests this
company means business
the name Minos refers to the mythical
first king of Crete
who presided over a labyrinth to which
young people will be brought for his
entertainments maze-like and practically
inescapable the participants would
typically die inside the labyrinth
killed by a monstrous Minotaur while the
movies escape room isn't particularly
maze like the idea of people being lured
there to die for others entertainments
proves especially relevant by the time
the ending rolls around and the true
nature of the company is revealed after
the escape game reveals its deadly
nature the surviving players start to
uncover what is true purposes Mike Ben
Zoe and Jason enter a room that's mucked
up to resemble a hospital several
hospitals are chilly with each player
finding something familiar they realize
the setup is meant to remind them of
past traumatic experiences in which they
emerged as a lone survivors Zoe survived
the plane crash
Jason survived the boating accidents
Mike survived the mining accidents and
Ben survived a fatal drunk driving
collision as Zoe describes it they are
all statistical anomalies this aspect of
the game is more than just psychological
as the game master reveals in the final
chamber the contest was set up
specifically to pit lone survivors
against each other for the sake of
seeing what would happen when these
lucky few competes upon discovering the
game's true nature something inside Zoe
snaps while all of the other players set
about attempting to solve a puzzle
Zoe goes berserk and starts smashing
every camera in the room she guesses up
the people in charge of the game aren't
just observing their play but actively
involving themselves in it something
that would be impossible if she takes
away their ability to watch watching us
they know everyone
as poisonous gas fills the room the
other players flee leaving Xabi behind
that she insists on finishing the job
she survives the gas by breathing
through an oxygen mask knowing that no
one can see she's still alive while the
Mino staff comes to clear out the
chamber they assume she's dead until she
attacks Danny the avid gamer who met his
end by drowning in the cold room
previously insisted that brute force
shouldn't be necessary to win the game
but in this instance it might be the
only way while Zoey practices a
gamebreaking gambits then presses
forward to the final room where he meets
a man who describes himself as the game
master Venice declared the winner
while the GM monologues like a super
villain spilling all the details of
Minos his motivations he reveals the
games or entertainments for wealthy
audiences like gladiator fights with
Ben's group of being the latest
iteration of a long line of twisted
games the contest he reveals is for the
benefit of no one but the viewers the
players aren't allowed to win the game
master then attempts to strangle Ben to
death before Zoe reappears and
intervenes together they kill the game
master and finally make their escape
after Bonanza we leave 24 hours pass
with Ben Ben checked into a hospital for
his injuries when Zoe is informed that
Ben is stable she's called away by
police to assist in their investigation
their findings are not encouraging back
at the Minos building the company is
nowhere to be found the facility is
being cleared out in a final insult
Zoe is haunted by a message on the wall
familiar only to her that reads Wu Tang
knew a mysterious name that previously
appeared in several rooms of the game
she realizes that a nonsense name is
actually an anagram that solves to no
way out six months later Ben and Zoe
catch up with each other in Chicago
while life is going well for Ben Zoe is
still seeking closure the bodies of
their fellow players she discovers were
scattered around the world with their
deaths made to look like accidents the
scheme sits poorly with Zoe's sense of
justice the world deserves to know what
really happened
Zoe manages to convince Ben to fly to
Minos his Manhattan headquarters the
coordinates of which she discovered
hidden in the companies logo they took a
flight to the city but it turns out
Minos has been watching and there's
already one step ahead in an epilogue
it's revealed that the people behind me
have designed a custom-made escape game
just for the two of them which they plan
to install on their flight they will
apparently have only a 4% chance of
surviving this game which seems to be
targeting them out of pure spite on a
monitor a shadowy silhouette figure
overseeing the operation says it's time
to play again jigsaw would be proud
escape room ends with a clear tease for
a sequel one that could demonstrate the
truly awesome reach of Minos it's the
only time that viewers get a real
glimpse behind the curtain and the
operation looks massive dozens of people
are involved with the design of the
plane escape game alone which makes you
wonder just how deep the rabbit-hole
goes
who is the shadowy figure overseeing the
game and what is the motivation behind
the conspiracy is it really just for
entertainment or could it be something
more whatever may come next the track
has been laid for some truly
off-the-rails insanity if a sequel gets
the green light you can count us in the
game check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]